[Music]
hey welcome everybody I'm Phil Molina
and this is rogue theory it's the show
where we just let our favorite people
come on to our channel and talk about
just nerdy stuff and theories and topics
and questions that are circling the
nerdist sphere today's episode we have
Maude Garrett she's back she is from mom
you can say the B word you can say it
way more than I can we also have Nate
Ballard who is my personal friend and
fixed my TV and this is my reward he's
also a local comedian that you can see
around town and later on we'll talk
about where and also so does marina
masters who we see around town yeah oh
that I would with handy person handy
non-binary there we go all right so
reminded that you can listen to this
show the rogue theory podcast on the
podcast feed all of our content comes
out faster on the podcast of you can't
wait go there also check out inside
Marvel that podcast to WikiLeaks podcast
that's empty you in Star Wars content on
this episode we got some theories about
all kinds of stuff we got some obviously
is in spider-man part from home stuff
because Sony was so nice to let us see
that earlier in the week this time
dude's a skit skit asti we're also gonna
talk about some stranger things news
season 3 which is looking but man the
outfits in that
[Music]
and also so what giant animal is on the
set we have a conversation about Game of
Thrones to spin off we got a little bit
of news coming out when you say Beast
that's like the only one there's the
beast from Marvel all right let's we'll
say I won that and I'll take a lot of
pride victory laughs careful and my
sister did say guys spider-man far from
home going into it I looked up the
runtime and I was like 2 hours and 10
minutes yes I know and I live on it
thank you
it flew by I thought I would feel the
two hours and 10 minutes did not feel it
at all it was it went by so quickly
sounds like you slipped I had my eyes
closed
yeah but it was the point that was the
point
I mean smoke and mirrors it's quite
quite literally there were smoke and
mirrors yeah okay cool so I'm glad
you're going down that route because
it's a very on brand for us to figure
out like what's it really about right so
it clearly is about illusions and truth
revealing because we've seen so many
iterations of Mysterio in the comics and
the one that I like the most is from
sorry to get my nerd on here but is from
old man Logan where we see Mysterio
basically single-handedly use Logan
anticipated mind make all of his people
in his head seem like all of the x-men
were actually villains and so he kills
everyone and I was like that Mysterio is
probably the big like the biggest threat
villain that we've seen since Dan oh so
you could just basically what exactly
that's the time where people realize
like that's something that the MCU does
really well
they realize someone's powers can
actually be used in like these terrible
insane ways instead of like oh you think
I'm over here I'm over here yeah or I'm
really big now but yeah and that he
murders the x-men yeah well he has
Wolverine do it so yeah let's talk about
about Mysterio would you guys think of
both Mysterio and Jake Gyllenhaal's yeah
Jake's Jake's were always good oh you
guys are oh if you know what I mean that
yeah I thought that it was very
reminiscent of Incredibles 1 the villain
yeah it's like I'm supposed to be on
your team but I'm actually yeah yeah
I'll say that I mean it's a little tough
I think for all of us that are familiar
with the character we're like well
that's a bad guy so that's gonna be a
reveal right and then right it did
happen but I actually thought that they
still made it super interesting
entertaining here's why for me
personally I like that they anchored it
through Ironman because that's the way
you could hurt Peter the most right
instead of a person mysterious oh it's
speaking of Mysterio from the comics
there's a version of him who's basically
failed actor he's dead from the theater
world and it kind of you know is this
idea of like oh I could put on shows and
performances it's like yeah that's fine
but instead to anchor him through I'm
gonna use your mentors technology
against you right and and both you're
gonna think of me as your replacement
mentor and then I'm actually your
biggest threat like all of that I
thought was a way better reimagining of
how to use Mysterio like I wonder what
his plan was if if Peter hadn't just
given the glasses like he couldn't plan
that to be like I'll talk him into doing
this at a bar to be fair he probably
could have made an illusion where Peter
thought his glasses were over here let
me grab this slice of cheese yeah so
what so then the real question is is
Peter really drinking lemonade
that scene yeah maybe his plan was just
to get him wasted right vodka oh yes
because he had to verbalize but he could
have been like we're shooting a
commercial and what a fun dare would be
just like transferring control
performance was amazing because you know
he does play the the hero so well
totally the mentor and you really see
him kind of like you know take up the
mantle of Tony Stark who was the mentor
and he kind of just looked right in
built instant trust on it and then the
switch and it was just so wonderful to
see Jake Gyllenhaal just shine but the
disgruntled employee we've seen it
before with like mr. enigma in like they
originally like Batman Sri Monica's
Batman series with Jim Carrey
like I really I stated and it's like
kind of like builds up this it's more
than disgruntlement it's like but using
the technology that they helped build
against them but I kind of like that you
know in a way we have this movie to
mourn Tony Stark and in a few months and
they use great exposition to kind of
like see how the world is moving on from
it all but Tony Stark obviously wanted
all of this notoriety at the start of
his career and because we've seen him
for so long over the movies you see that
he sacrificed everything for the sake of
humanity and yet he hasn't been able to
I guess protect his reputation so the
fact that you know he still is perceived
as a really dangerous guy to a lot of
people especially people who used to
work for him wrong though right like
he's famously an egomaniac and he would
admit that more than anyone in fact I
feel like that's what happy was trying
to say he's like yeah the guy was like
messed up but at the same time I signed
you the story of this messed-up guy must
have had such a good heart
we saw proof that he has heart right
that I he was able to wield this kind of
power and look how much good he did and
give this a fraction of the power to
this this team of people for moments and
look how much damage they immediately go
to do you know it's it's actually like a
love letter to Tony Stark I also think
he's saying like he was
so human-like he's not the yeah you know
the perceived brand he is he's he's
insecure just like everybody else kind
of thing they were clearly like having
that lingering question of who is the
next Tony Stark do you guys think that
this was trying to answer but some
people are saying what spider-man like
even though he's kind of saying I'm not
what that's literally exactly what it
meant
go ahead by the end of the movie I was
like yeah like Timmy the whole point in
the movie was like oh man at the
beginning Spiderman thinks he's not the
main like person to take up the mantle
and then it's the whole story story
story story story sir sir sir sir sir
Sir sir sorry and then the whole point
of the film like literally is that he is
and when he yet when he rises to that
moment that's when we see him at the
back of the airplane which I love by the
way just a shout-out to Chris McKenna I
think is one of the the screenwriters
who have believed it Lego Batman didn't
know but he did yeah he but he's the guy
who like he's really great at trope
deconstruction so why when you watching
Lego Batman it's like really realistic
too like BAM has probably an insane
person all the time and he puts on a bet
he's probably insane so he has like a
pool full of crazy toys and whatnot I he
did part of the the screenwriting of
this and I feel like you saw those
moments in on that plane scene where
he's kind of like so what are you gonna
do and he's like I'm gonna kick his ass
just finding all those moments that are
and then just Aberdeen they all stood
with the Sam Jackson like here's the
plan or the mission seeing that people
keep interrupting by knocking on the
door like is the music kicking in and
out but now we know that that was oh
right yeah so okay so getting in I guess
spoiler warning way too late I'm kidding
or not
yeah yeah we'll put a spoiler warning at
the beginning of this something we're
talking about spider-man from like the
whole thing is a spoiler if you haven't
seen it yet just a couple like lingering
questions that I had coming out but I
wonder you guys take on it one do you
guys think Mysterio is dead he got shot
for sure there's a really great moment
where it turns out he wasn't down there
right he was standing there yeah but
didn't he he died from like the original
gun shot right so what other recruit in
the moment what happens there is that he
basically collapses down and you know
dies when a Peter and Peter ass Edith is
this real and she says that all of the
visualizations she does not say he is
dead which is a pet peeve of mine guys
when people don't directly answer your
question which is such an important
question yeah technically you haven't
answered my question do you think he's
still alive I don't know I mean I really
like hit the character and I think that
there is a lot more room to go and grow
with it I would love to see him back
again or maybe we actually do have the
multiverse notion of mr. great so let's
take a boat real quick is this guy gonna
come back I want him to I think he's
gonna come back like got a TV right here
what these trips go to um we're
following this metaphor right okay so
then the chips they disappear VCR it's
the Phantom chips oh so the chip that
left the video for spider-man and for
the world like spider-man killed me this
this chip leaves this video and says but
has more plans from the past like has
done mine like pull more strings that we
haven't seen you yeah interesting Marino
what do you think that means
well think of it like a TV right I think
this is an unrelated reason but gunshots
are like you can stay alive so long
after you get shot how do you know that
okay I'll tell you how I know that
watching like all literally all the
seasons of I survived which is a TV show
about people who have survived like
horrific events but a bunch of them have
been shot guys they were on a tangent
now have been shot and he got shot in
the like abdomen so he was the liver it
would kill him but it would take a
little while to it would take awhile and
also we don't like it we're assuming he
got shot because but also that was part
of the illusion because he was standing
over there probably did also bullets oh
my god deep now right he could he could
have just been pretend like acting like
you sure well clearly our post-credit
scene shows that there's also either he
okay here's what I'll throw out there in
the comics there's more than one
Mysterio to so the technology somebody
else could easily wear that illusion
holds face and let's be a good happy
face because that could be a little guy
from from another Iron Man one of the
lattices yes pull out that drive so
maybe yes downloading yeah I mean if I
have that tech I'm gonna look like Jake
Gyllenhaal in MCU now where it's like
there's almost room for anything to
happen at any time always we've got
Scrolls in this universe now so it
doesn't necessarily mean that that
person really is that person at any one
time we have time travel now so any
event that actually happens doesn't mean
that's going to exist for the rest of
time as that particular way and path and
then if you've got this illusion
technology then what the hell what what
is real anymore I'm not even real I'm
not really here I'm in bed at the moment
like nothing buffering way more like you
would like not be working well we don't
get internet okay different question so
I know I recorded all your answers and
we'll find you if you're wrong but to
collect but I also want to point out
this movie did a lot of advancing of the
overall MCU story now right we do know
Scrolls are out their lips but the blip
is now the the decimation is now
referred to as a blip it doesn't it
didn't need a new name because the
people came back I think blip really
under but so speaking on that really
quick so they they had two moments that
I want one I want acknowledged really
quick how funny it was the idea that the
teachers wife faked and but the thing I
want to talk about more is actually is
it marks at the name of the the
alternate love interest the one real
memorable name is what it was but yeah
I'm not sure but the the idea that he
actually was one of the people who did
not get dusted right and so they're all
talking about him as if he's so weird
like it's so weird he's he's handsome
now and older and cool another and it's
like no he lived normal you all died and
disappeared too in word maybe this whole
stone or something who knows and then
for five years and then you guys came
back and got reintegrated right so my
question is who is actually having a
weirder life and which side would you
rather be on well I can tell you that
the weirder life would be living being
around for those five nights and also
having to stay in school and your
classes you would think you'd even if
you move somewhere else you'd still home
school or something like so well mostly
just the the bean in that chaotic world
that is chaotic
go to the grocery store so well no I
mean are there there we saw in endgame
like all the ships like that it's almost
like trade
gotten thrown off you know like like the
world was not functioning well
economically would you rather not exist
or would you rather miss half of your
friends and family I probably I'd rather
not exist the other people got the crap
in it like five years of their life
without their significant others so mad
when they came back you'd be so mad at
them and be like I'm warned you just
back and you think we're still in a
relationship over it but you're in high
school you know gays exactly and also
all of our leads were dusted so you know
we are we're on their side but really
these people suffered and like they're
like making fun of you take pictures in
the bathroom and it's like I go to
therapy every man the one benefit is
they will die five years earlier than
their counterparts would have great hey
real quick let's kick to some sponsors
that helped us put the show together and
are helping pay for that TV to get fixed
rogue theories brought to you by some
very nice sponsors do you have credit
card debt and are tired of the high
interest rates people that are way
smarter than me with money stuff are
always saying you should consolidate
that debt and get a lower interest rate
if you pay less interest on your debt
you can pay your credit cards off faster
and start saving money money could use
to buy a car or house trip to comic-con
next year it's very expensive get a
credit card consolidation loan from
light stream with rates as low as five
point nine five percent APR with auto
pay light stream is super easy to use
you can apply on your phone and have
money in your bank account as soon as
the day you applied they don't charge
fees and the interest rate is fixed so
it'll never go up over the life of the
loan just for our listeners apply now to
get a special interest rate discount the
only way to get this discount is to go
to light stream comm slash rock stars
again for the peeps in the back that's
light stream comm slash rock stars Li gh
TS tream comm slash rock stars it's all
of course subject to credit approval and
that rate includes a point five percent
auto paid discount terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit light stream comm
slash rock stars for more information
hey if there's a part of your body that
you don't want to harm while shaving
it's the no undercarriage bit
there that's why manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer their
lawnmower 2.0 has proprietary skin-safe
technology so this trimmer won't nikkor
snag you in that real sensitive place
you also shouldn't be using the same
trimmer on your face as you use in below
the belt kind of like using a sock for a
napkin it's very gross you could do
better
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels they're
number one in men's below the belt
grooming get 20% off free shipping and a
free travel bag with the code rock stars
at manscaped comm has 20% off with free
shipping and a free travel bag at
manscape comm when you use the code
rockstars
thanks so much and we're back and still
in spider-man for another few people -
there's still stuff that we want to talk
about so here's here's the last thing I
want to touch on because it's it's huge
post-credit scene specifically so the
scroll one great confirmed we what we
thought were like scroll questioning but
j jonah Jameson first of all they did
what everyone was kind of like joking
like oh if they can keep JK Simmons like
that'd be amazing then they were like
yeah yeah I'd be me and my theatre - JK
is the only true PJ you can get like I
understand that it's crossing worlds or
whatever and it could cause some
confusion I don't think that's the case
and it was you guys weren't here last
week but we were kind of just throwing
out what what if they brought him what
it could be like and I think one of us
did actually say like it feels too old
to be a newspaper editor yeah it's got
to be something more modern like a vlog
or an info words I think we made a joke
that he was like Alex Jones one had also
played in thematically about essentially
the whole movie is about fake news that
he's taking there but what he reveals is
spider-man secret identity right to the
world it was the best and worst moment
because it was like holy hell like this
is the new game this
not what I saw coming this changes
absolutely everything but then a part of
me was like we're never gonna see Peter
Parker get a job at the Daily Bugle
we're never gonna see him work with
spider-man yeah he can't he can't
pretend I got these pictures of
spider-man somehow but at the same time
it's like you know this iteration of
spider-man isn't the traditional
spider-man that we've seen twice now in
movies we haven't seen an Uncle Ben pass
away and have the whole with great
responsibility comes great
responsibility if anything Tony Stark
maybe play down the role a little bit
more or it's gonna be happy and happy
his real name is Ben but the thing I
want to get to is so where do we think
this is all going you know what are we
gonna see now from Peter now that the
world knows thing and just a reminder
that you guys probably know but I'll
throw out there in the comics this event
happens with civil war where Tony has
convinced spider-man to side with him in
the Accords and he has to in order to
put his name down and register hey I'm a
superhero he had say hey also my name is
Peter Parker it's a famous cover i but
that obviously didn't happen for this
one because he would have had to reveal
himself the first moment we meet him but
where do we think they're gonna take it
then I mean in in stepping into like
being the new Tony Stark like Tony Stark
was all about like I'm Tony Stark right
like I mean this is my name this is my
image like everything is about me and
like even though he doesn't want to do
it that way like he's being forced to
now literally be that role of like this
is who I am this is my actual identity
like and see how he does it and I think
the problem the only problem he faces
right now besides it besides the rest of
the world is the fact that Jake
Gyllenhaal was like this he killed me
and he's done bad things so now people
are me against him so they're not just
knowing who he is now they're gonna be
like knocking on his door and being like
don't help me a little bit Dark Knight
right here oh we deserve is there any
Marvel hero in all the vendors or the
new upcoming that have a hidden identity
so that's something that we're talking
about a lot of them have code names
right but the faces are exploits but
it's pretty well known who they are but
the classic superhero issue is the
moment people know you are the people
you love are in danger they'll take them
out so
is probably the biggest concern it does
make me think of what I have two
theories for how II think they could do
it one I'll say real quickly yeah
wait no no yeah you should have been
listening though one is a scroll they'll
use a scroll to be Peter right how is
how is it that I'm I'm spider-man
there's a guy right here that looks just
like that and then that would be a
little but I think that'd be a little
too easy so they could also instead do
one more day from the comics which is
when Spiderman has revealed his identity
there's an assassin sent after him from
kingpin and it gets Aunt May killed I
and so he's just having like this
terrible time so he I don't know how
I'll do this part but he makes a deal
with essentially a demon to undo all of
this and make it so that he can get a
secret identity back but it also undoes
his marriage to Mary Jane but it brings
back on May so he could at right when he
has everything he wants he loses he
loses a child out of it you know well he
could also let Doctor Strange
have him go back in time I guess the
past new universe and kills his cool
alright so obviously we have a lot of
theories about where this can go and I
so excited to not know what the answer
is for like years and years and years
and man they're really gonna slow down
you know that's it probably Marvel
movies for a while now wonder well we
have the shows on the Disney Plus thing
but we'll see one vision on yet telly
[Music]
which is very much trying to be like you
guys are TV people so let's move on to
stranger things you guys seen these
trailers and then also so the season is
about to drop it's all of our favorite
preteens again fighting a another
monster clouds lots of yeah it's it's a
kind of like a mysterious storm thing so
here's my thing about it I feel like
season one of
things was about Dungeons and Dragons
yes but but in a way that version of
them it's about embracing the stranger
right both literally being weird and
being okay with being the outcast even
Nancy goes with the weirder boyfriend
than the cooler introduced to a strange
stranger in 11:00 and accepting that
people think is crazy right but but
she's actually a time the truth so it's
just always about that I feel like
season two is a lot about embrace
welcome back will it is it is
appropriate that you're saying that you
want to hold him like a baby because I
think season two is all about parenting
and family and accepting you know
everybody had a role of either being a
parent or a child in that season for
Dustin and the little creature 11 and
hopper like they call Steve their mom so
season 3 I'm just gonna throw out there
a pitch for what it might be about
hormones exactly puberty yeah yeah so I
want to know right before we watch it
cuz we don't watch it yet what you guys
think puberty in the word world of
stranger things is bow-chicka-wow-wow
porno yeah you're getting the lhasa
fueled up with the lifeguard at the pool
moment which is very reminiscent of the
Sandlot yeah I mean just get a Wendy
peppercorn right now and then you know
they're growing older they work 13 years
yeah that's when I had no it wasn't I
feel like I should move it back to
stranger things but instead I want to
know Maude what's the rest of that
sentence
my first kiss at 14 Oh 13 so Wow I was
15 okay 15 okay and any day now right
[Laughter]
but we know what is the older brother
the bully that no one really likes to do
so sexy we can't hate him he's infected
right yeah he's gonna be infected and
tend to some sort of like he is well on
how that applies to puberty I want to
know what does puberty look like in
there a lot of things in weed places
that you never thought it would be I
think he actually does turn into some
sort of like shadow D the one that we
monster yeah he's like trying weird
gross this is weird I don't know I feel
funny and then instead of it being
puberty he's really transforming until I
could did you know to be nuts but it too
much on the nose but he could represent
you know like toxic masculinity if you
don't interesting you know you're you
have all these hormones he's a bit of a
dick oh yeah he's emotionally right and
then so if you don't like constantly
keep yourself connected and like you
know get your emotions out then it can
become addict yeah is that does that
start at puberty for us that when did we
become toxic masculine
I'd say probably 13 yeah yeah well
that's certainly when you're at your
worst yeah exactly
have to learn how to control them so
that so and if you don't then it's bad
I'm being very profound you guys another
younger female into the mix into the
know as well so we're looking at they're
gonna be pairing off this is like at
school dance all the boys on one side
all the girls I'm not gonna start you
know what's really funny is if you watch
if you know what I mean or just dancing
so if you watch is it behind strangers
they be on stranger things I they with
the principal from community exactly so
they did
interview with the cast and the moment
that the kids are so clearly like giddy
and freaking out about is what the
problem exactly they and the big kiss
and they talk about the various
characters that we're gonna need to kiss
and like apparently onset is like such a
big deal to these kids because it's some
it is their first and they're actually
having like their first kiss with
probably let's be honest they probably
have crushes on each other right they
were like 11 or 12 or something oh no no
I think maybe a little older actually
but now they're like a couple years past
that they're all literally going through
puberty together like I think they're
actually probably having the like freak
out chemistry it's the camp environment
you know when you when you are like kids
put together
yeah they Paul you're just like having
all sorts of fun drama yeah yeah so talk
about the Game of Thrones spin up yeah
because you know what does that mean
never die and it's appropriate I mean
that joke did you guys ever say Candyman
a bunch times in the mirror so okay so
two leaks came out this week from the
set of The Game of Thrones prequel
series it's shooting in Northern Ireland
and there's this leaked title logo for
what they're calling right now at least
Blood Moon first of all there's another
leak we get will talk about a second but
I just want some guesses as to what you
think Blood Moon would refer the blood
moon rises that's one breath of the wild
that's what Zelda says to link we know
that yeah that's when all the bad guys
yeah yeah yeah do you think and I
apologize profusely but it's a period
yeah on that then I think that maybe it
has to do with how the White Walkers
came to be and blood sacrifice okay I
thought castles nurse could hear your
goal yeah alright so no go into this
though seriously like you think it has
to do with with how the way
they're gonna come yeah Sorey I want to
see yeah I mean this is almost mystery I
feel like they left on untouched like we
didn't get as fact truly ended that one
where was like what there was the
antagonist the entire series let's find
out the start of it interesting the way
you said unsatisfactorily was amazing by
the way a second ago like I think it was
actually channeled Alan Rickman Snape I
think it could be yeah
so I do think that it probably could be
with that because to me Blood Moon is
screaming maybe like a Lord of Light
kind of thing and where these religions
all came from it'd be very interesting
yeah the originals were high does have a
prehistoric element supposedly this
spinoff series so one thing I'm also
really excited about it was the other
leaked thing which is that they're gonna
be in space that's why I didn't ask you
no way do you really mean that no he's
gonna be in a space you lost your spot
to reminding us that nate is keeping
story and now we are going to hold you
to that we're about to talk about kinda
okay for listeners marina has a
obsession with dinosaurs and we've been
tried told not to bring it up she will
go we got to close because there were
mammoths supposedly a scene on this set
I don't think actual mammoths but it
seems like over the north there's not
around no they're in the history books
when when in the world of this thing
like when they read their own history
books right there are mammoths in their
own hips well they're supposed to be
mammoths in the wildling army mmm
and then also there's the elephant army
which we did not see yeah yeah yeah but
what other mythical animals you think
we're gonna see spiders please my gosh
they're in the walls I've talked about
them and said it she laid the foundation
give us BIOS probably some Triceratops
probably Rex probably some velociraptor
I'm also joking definitely gonna see
like for sure but you know what we
should jump right into just some quick
ro questions which is all of us these
are questions that we don't know what
they say but we are going to just throw
out our answers as they come to them
okay Melissa McCarthy has been rumored
to self burn what is let's see a best
someone's best Ursula impression yeah
pretty face but don't underestimate the
importance of is anyone gonna do an
impression those were all very good and
then who should play Sebastian I wanted
awkwafina is scuttle because she's
alright
Stuber is coming out next weekend so
dave bautista is a cop an undercover cop
right and he's takes an uber with Kumail
Nanjiani as the driver comes out next
week weekend comedy ruber what fictional
character would you least want to share
an uber with least want to poke that's
very thank you
why he's too wide and then he would be
like a crown for it and then he'd ripped
the top off and then he'd probably throw
me out I'm sure right with Homer Simpson
really yeah least give her the points
all right
if you had a scroll doppelganger which
we learned is an option now what would
you have them do for you she's already
doing it Vera Farmiga she's crushing it
as an actress making you would rather
have your scroll doppelganger crushes an
actress and you live I don't make the
rules everybody for me are you dating a
lot of people like when you have to
break up you tag them in alright you
trust them to take care of that for you
[Laughter]
you're beautiful I do not need to your
car is good then you could just text the
whole time and you don't have to wait so
why do they have to be you look in the
window be like what there's two of them
there's yeah I'm not why does one join
up the other one in the backseat exactly
I'm pulling this over I think this is a
scroll situation yeah why is also one
way heavier than the other one these are
weird Peter gets to build his own custom
Spidey suit with the stark technology
and far from home how would you improve
a Spidey suit for you specifically my
meals no invisibility is pretty good I'm
gonna call out cuz what Peter came up
with was a spider shaped parachute which
does not seem better than a normal
parachute turn into a dinosaur but of
course you would
but leader like claws and stuff dinosaur
claws come on guys or like shoot tiny
dinosaurs out of my hands or you know
like which dinosaur specifically are you
shooting out of your hands
Oh which one am i shooting my hands the
ones that but tiny versions we fixed it
guys speaking of still in far from home
everyone calls the spider-sense the
Peter tingle that's a critical
masturbation you're Peter tingle how
about that banana rotten banana
yes his face and it hit him in the face
and then immediately uncomfortable where
every time she brings it up he's like oh
don't say that correct so the kid is
older than his brother
we know what it was supposed to be right
it's a spidey sense what would you name
your super intuition and the card writer
wrote like I've got a fillip feelers
what motion the mod motion yes Serena
mindset sounds like a series of
self-help CDs - can free yourself from
your love of dinosaurs it's a good
American accent that's satisfying
napkins it was it was the - it was the
alliteration that you really like well
napkin is the last answer section guys
that's it for this episode of rogue
theory thank you so much you guys
you guys went rogue with us we went to
really weird places we found out how
many times have each been shot which is
a nonzero number
all right thanks to our guest Maude
Garrett where can we find you ah I'm
Maude Garrett on all social medias and
I've got a YouTube channel called geek
bomb and it's very good and I like it
she also has a lot of interviews with
Keanu yeah and on I didn't and far from
home junket interviews with the cast on
Nerdist go Nate
well yet at a thread corner podcast it's
a podcast about knitting about TV making
damn it TV fixing there's some comedy
and it's it's I can get into it it's
gonna be long just tell us it in one
second
it's podcast twins brother dies so the
other brother decides to recreate the
podcast because that first podcast never
got released
now he's recreating each episode guys do
check this out say it again yes you just
brought him I'm Fred weathers well it's
worth it
you might wanna start from beginning but
something you can just jump in anywhere
but you'll find some value somewhere
what can we see perform at Second City
every other Saturday ish and Second City
Hollywood Second City Hollywood and then
Thursday nights at the moving arts
theater on Hyperion that's more of a
like rocking nude comedy yeah yeah punk
rock you gotta be over 21 you got to be
able to not wear clothes hey we're all
marine awake anybody I'm on Twitter at
Marina Mastro's and I have a podcast
called camp out creeps which is about
demons and scary stuff but it's a comedy
podcast so it's just us freaking out
about all things scary and I'm on a team
at UCB which is called sassy Bluff and
we're every last Wednesday at 7:00 at
UCB Sunset great like the last Wednesday
the 4th I guess yeah go in a time
machine every bug go to a week ago
Wednesday get out go to the UCB sunset
watch it in the past
I'll be there guys I will be there
because you guys are very funny and I
really enjoy supporting you guys and I
want you guys back here again you guys
thank you so much for supporting us by
watching this and enjoying it and
subscribing to the podcast feed and
subscribing to the channel stay tuned to
the YouTube channel by the way for way
more spider-man far from home stuff
we're also obviously gonna cover
stranger things and coming up this week
Eric will be on vacation for a little
bit but then he comes right back and
it's all gonna be fine I promise
that's his vacation he gets to go into
living room follows aDNA rock stars me I
thought Melina have a good night
[Music]